i get a lot of questions about
programming but i don't think
they're the right questions to ask
questions like how many languages do i
need to learn
what language do i need to learn to get
to company x what's the difference
between a
and b and which makes more money what
are the exact steps i need to take
to become z what kind of program should
i write to build up my resume
so why don't i like these questions
because it feels like the people who are
asking these questions they are learning
how to program just for the sake
of learning how to program but
programming is just a tool
being a programmer for me means you
write code to automate things
or to make things perform certain
actions for example programming a
refrigerator to turn on the light when
you open the door
when you think about it programming is
actually kind of boring
you're just giving a series of
instructions to a machine
over and over again until you get it
right i don't want to speak for all of
you
but i think if the pay wasn't great i
don't think a lot
of you would spend hours and hours every
night in front of your computer
trying to learn how to code or to just
debug your program
sometimes we get caught up learning
languages or doing coding challenges or
fantasizing about
you know working for these big tech
companies that
we forget why we wanted to learn
programming in the first place
you wanted to program because you saw
the amazing things
that can be built using programming so
don't just learn how to program
build something that matters build
something that means something to you
build something that solves a problem
you're a problem solver
a creator an innovator you're not a
programmer
programming is just a tool in your
arsenal to build something amazing
you can be analytical creative
empathetic and programming allows you to
express those qualities of yourself
but programming in of itself is nothing
special
it's like a pencil it can mark stuff
down if you press on the pencil hard
enough
that's it but with a pencil you can
write novels draw beautiful portraits
build plans for a skyscraper
or anything limited only by your
imagination
you don't learn how to program to get
into google
you learn how to program to build
something meaningful something that
helps real people with real problems
i'm partnered with ibm today to talk
about a global initiative called
call for code which calls for developers
to build something impactful
and have a positive change across the
world through their code
as you know there are hundreds and
hundreds of natural disasters every year
like hurricanes earthquakes floods
volcanoes and wildfires
those affect numerous lives and causes
tremendous damage to
many families around the world if you
strive for real impact
we desperately need you this is why 2018
call for code global challenge
is a competition that asks people like
you to build solutions to improve what
we can do to reduce
disruptive impact of these natural
disasters we need all kinds of
technologies
you like working on blockchains build
secure supply networks to help
distribute aid to the people in need
you like ai or nlp make bots to help
real-time communications to them
you're into data science analyze and
predict what the affected population
needs before they even ask for it every
one of your project will matter
and it will be for an extremely good
cause now of course it is still a
competition
so they have a grand prize of two
hundred thousand dollars
not only that the project the greatest
potential impact
will be implemented with the help of ibm
the linux foundation
the un human rights and the american red
cross
so are you up for the challenge so don't
forget don't be a programmer
be a problem solver join a call for code